you are best friends with jerry seinfeld
you guys were roommates i think for
over a decade you guys were roommates
he's an idiot
now you know
he's an idiot huh yeah he seems not a
smart guy is he
oh don't you ever say that in front of
him because like seinfeld like he's uh
eight years in a row with one year on
fortune magazine he was the number one
money-making comedian
in the world in the world kevin hart
beat him out one year
and so he think he knows everything and
he's first to tell me because i don't
want to tell him shut up
you have no idea what you're talking
about everybody else all the other
comedians yeah jerry yeah whatever he
says it goes good
i don't take that i talk to him like a
little brother i tell them to shut up
you don't know everything you think you
know this you don't know that
he tells me check the list check the
list he's number one on the list that's
all that's
his back up check the list he's got too
much money i mean you and i we're doing
real good we're doing real good but yeah
he's he's he's up there different these
rich people man
i go to the house i mean just too rich i
go to his house on the island and the
land and the prophet is so
big i mean when you punch in the
security code at the gate
waze is still giving you directions to
the house
[Laughter]
just to get from the gate to the front
door you need ways
and 2 000 feet you will have reached
your just
[Laughter]
and you get in the house he doesn't like
me to talk about this how rich
they are and i'm going to catch hell for
doing this but i'm at his house
i got up at three o'clock in the morning
i went to pee i
come back my bed is made
and there's a guy said chocolate on my
pillow
it's crazy but i i do take advantage of
his friendship
yeah well you should you should and you
know what he needs you
because he's got too many yes people
around him telling him he's a genius
he needs you george he needs a guy like
you telling him
you don't know what you're talking about
and you've got too much money that's
that's what he's 45 years 45 years best
friends for 45 years we started a club
called catch rising star in the coming
strip of new york city
but we've been best friends for 45 years
i wish
everybody had a friend like seinfeld and
it's just amazing um
and yes i'm actually the real roommate
i'm actually the real georgian ribbon
for 13 years we were roommates and uh
i was best man in his wedding and i'm
the father his kids also
[Laughter]
hey george that's been obvious for some
time
when you see the kids you go they look a
little dark